everyone we're here at e3 2017 I'm Tomas
and joined by Alex Newhouse and we've
played one of the hottest games of e3
2017 so far yeah Mario plush rabbits
Kingdom battle yeah the most
unexpectedly cool game from year 2017 I
think it's been ruined for a while
people have had mixed reception to
they've been like do we really need
Rabbids in mario verse and turns out you
do cuz it's real cold yeah yeah so we
played it yesterday and we both came out
thinking it's basically XCOM with
rabbits and Mario in there yeah I think
probably the most surprising thing is
it's not a toned-down watered down
strategy game it's actually really in
depth and really involved right yeah so
it's got a lot of the complexities that
you are kind of familiar with from the
recent XCOM games we're gonna be talking
about XCOM and referencing it a lot
because it seems like they have very
much looked to it for inspiration and
it's being developed in house ubisoft
entirely and they don't have a lot of
experience with turn-based strategy
games they have some and so it makes
sense for them to look at one of the
best and use that and like for example
one of the abilities that you use was
overwatch yeah yeah so in in XCOM it's
like you set your character to overwatch
and in this it was Mario right so yeah
any enemy that moves within his lions
line-of-sight he'll jump out and kind of
like shoot him yeah and it was really
unexpected too I had Mario up against
cover because you can go into cover as
well that's really important and a
rabbit ran across Mario's line of sight
and then Mario just sniped him yeah
they've all got like Mega Man style
blasters no and you can upgrade those as
well so one of the mechanics was the
coin mechanic right so did you get the
upgrade for that yeah you I got good you
have to get the eight red coins like
you're doing most Mario games and then
once you get that in unlocks a treasure
chest and if you open that and you get a
special weapon yeah and it does the
audio cues as well like there and then
you get the last one and the chest
appears and it opens up and I think I
got me like the turtle shell spike
terminal blaster which was really cool
and they kind of kept all the
fundamentals of a Mario game in there so
you're not kind of your movement isn't
isn't just turn-based like one by one
movement you have an exploration phase
yeah well you have that little blue
kind of radar thing that you're actually
controlling and all the characters run
behind it
and then you go into like a battle phase
so you get a bit of like the classic
Mario platforming style thing and it's
really really like familiar it feels
good and the world around you is very
colorful and you can like stop to look
at things you see rabbits doing stupid
stuff and they give you a lot of like
colorful pegs yeah there's a bit of like
Mario 3d World in there I think yeah
just moving around seeing things
happening in the background rabbits
going crazy everywhere yeah so one of
the big battles that we had you
completed it I got killed in it which
speaks to how kind of difficult it can
be I'm not great at strategy games but
even I can I've completed XCOM so like I
find it difficult but it was a lot of
complexity in the way that kind of
battlefield was built right do you want
to tell yeah so you have the battlefield
and you have a bunch of little barriers
on the ground and the Piranha player on
a plant yeah a hybrid between those the
battleground also had some verticality
like there are two ledges upon which
like rabbits were hanging out taking
potshots and your characters down on the
ground and they had like different types
you have the breakable blocks brick
blocks which you kind of shoot through
to come out destroy cover but you also
have like explosive barrels and other
barrels like foxes that I would knock
out like obstacles and that kind of
stuff and there's also a lot to the
movement within the kind of power also
and you can run around turn-based but
you can also do like team-up attacks you
actually saw in the thing so if you run
like a rabbit or my rabbit runs out
Mario and you like selected their
character they're kind of leapfrog off
each other so you can get around the map
that quick and this pipes as well and
you can combine all this stuff together
and like instead of just moving from one
point to the other you can do like oh
I'll run into the pipe and then run
along and there as long as you kind of
chain these movements together it
doesn't break your turn so you can go
from behind a box into a pipe along kind
of like another surface and down another
pipe and then onto an enemy and get
leapfrogged over and if you see enemies
in between you can attack them and do
like a slide tackle and then carry on
running so there's a lot of like
momentum
yeah it feels very much like platforming
active the way that a Mario game would
be it's extremely involves and I think
you were a little bit MIT v mixed on the
dash mechanic yeah but I thought it was
kind of cool you could dash into an
enemy hop on them and then you know run
around cover and then shoot them again
yeah I like the idea of the dash
mechanic it's just the way it's kind of
visualized because he'll like Mario will
dash into them and then kind of reroute
his dash to carry on his a kind of food
feels like he needs to stop after his
dash and then just run but it just looks
a bit odd but I think overall we came
away thinking it was very very exciting
like I'm surprisingly good a lot of
depth to it I think a lot of people are
gonna be really interested in and enjoy
it like anything a switch game so yeah
portable yeah like an apple XCOM with
Mario overlay like what more can you ask
for I think I think we both agree that's
one of the surprises and their best
games of e3 so far yeah cool well that's
our impressions on Mario Plus Rabbids a
Kingdom battle and for more videos on
that game and all the other games at e3
make sure you keep around the game
support YouTube channel and check out
our last streams on Twitch and we'll see
you next time